react.js a half-baked functional ui
library created at facebook that's used
by millions of developers because it has
a cool name and logo it was invented by
mark zuckerberg in 2013. and that was a
big mistake
and it was my mistake and i'm sorry
react is simple it's just javascript bro
and that's why it gives you dozens of
weird ways to solve the same problems
like functional and class-based
components hooks forward ref higher
order components mix-ins render props
suspense and so on it's credited as the
first declarative ui library even though
it took most of those ideas from
angularjs its killer feature though is
the fact that you can write pure
functional code that is until you want
to do anything useful in which case
you'll need to write imper functions
with state and effects the beauty of
this approach is that it makes simple
things like reactive state much more
complicated than they need to be and
that's what makes us feel like real
developers use effect is especially fun
and was originally going to be called
use foot gun because it's a great way to
introduce infinite loops performance
issues and bugs that you'll never be
able to figure out not to worry though
react is always evolving with
revolutionary new features to monkey
patch all the weirdness nobody saw
coming on the previous release now even
though it has an extremely high learning
curve react is a library and not a
framework and that means to build
something cool you'll need to find and
install hundreds of different packages
most of which were built by teenagers
who stopped maintaining them years ago
when they went off to college to learn a
real language like c to get started
create a new react app then open up
google to enter the gates of tutorial
hell notice how we start in strict mode
that's used to hide baggage from
previous versions of the framework i
mean library now in the code we pretend
we're doing functional programming by
writing our components as functions
classes are also possible but they are
literally the double instead we use
these hooks everywhere that do the same
[ __ ] classes do in a more magical
hipstery way templating is handled in
jsx it's a non-standard way to write
html which allows you to represent the
ui entirely in non-portable callback
hell now we can all agree to hate css
but react will make you hate it even
more when you try to style something on
your own luckily there are hundreds of
css and js libraries working on this
problem as we speak the extra complexity
is worth it though because react is
blazingly fast assuming you implemented
all the weird tricks flawlessly life is
about suffering it's not supposed to be
fun like spelt or fast like solid or
reliable like angular or all of the
above like view the only thing that
matters is react is the most popular and
that makes it undeniably the best just
like microsoft makes the best operating
system and mcdonald's makes the best
food this has been me destroying my
reputation with the react community in
100 seconds react has been the most
influential library in front of web
development for the last decade
nothing's perfect but it got to where it
is today because it does a lot of things
right and for that it deserves our
respect thanks for watching and i will
see you in the next one